j'ai sauvé Alstom en 2003 2004 quand
c'était en grande difficulté je suis
pour qu'on
défende cette entreprise et son
implantation à Belfort je soutiens
évidemment le gouvernement dans son bras
de fer mais le gouvernement agit bien
tardivement je rappelle que le
gouvernement a est au capital d'Alstom
qu'il avait le temps de voir venir et
que d'autre part nous payons là l'échec
de la politique ferroviaire du
gouvernement qui supprimant l'écotaxe
c'est contraint à ne plus avoir les
financements pour permettre un
aménagement du territoire national qui
donne au fer au rail toute sa place donc
Vous sanctionnez doublement le le
gouvernement est-ce qu'il y a eu selon
vous défaillances et vacances du
gouvernement puisque vous nous dites
effectivement qu' l'avz tout pour être
informé vacan défaillances quand je vois
que les élus j'entendrai Cédric berin le
sénateur de bfort à l'instant quand je
vois que les élus sont former aussi
tardivement et que l'État est
actionnaire à 20 % mais qu'a fait l'état
dans tout cela et là se pose la question
de Monsieur Macron parce que depuis un
il a négligé ces dossier vous voulez
dire ce dossier on le voit venir ça ne
se prend pas comme ça une décision de
cette nature et quand on a supprimé les
cotaxes on a supprimé les
investissements des régions en matière
ferroviaire on a supprimé les
modernisation en grande partie de
laasncf et donc en ne donnant pas les
moyens aux train notamment parce qu'on
n' pas fait l'écotaxe on se trouve dans
la situation aujourd'hui de déficit donc
les responsabilités sur ce dossier sont
lourdes alors aujourd'hui on soutient le
bras de fer mais on on pense quand même
que les choses auraient pu être traitées
autrement